i made a promise to hurt them the way we
heard
this season is so good and it seems like
you guys think it might be the best one
yet
i do i gotta say i do i mean i know it
sounds like lip service but
i'm so proud of this season you have
destroyed
my land i binge watched it all till four
in the morning
this season is so good
binge watch i'm like oh you need
psychiatric help then
in that case all handmaid's tale fans do
and that's okay
i feel like i never know what's gonna
happen um
because they surprise you in the most
wonderful way
find her and bring her to me
i would literally read the script and
stand up
and think are you kidding it's such a
kind of
cliffhangery season season four is as
dark
and twisted as ever and now elizabeth is
also calling the shots
as a director i ask for justice it was
definitely the hardest thing i've ever
done
bradley whitford and lizzie moss as he
calls her had a history long before
handmaid's
she was only 17 when she started on the
west wing drop the spoon
i knew it was you the way i feel about
lizzie is this kind of parental
pride of of this person who i met as a
kid who has become
someone who's a creative leader in
my creative life you know it's it's
really incredible
also new and streaming on apple tv plus
friday melissa george and justin thoreau
star in the mosquito coast
for justin it was a family affair but
has he been saying his own name wrong
for all these years the mosquito coast
was written by my uncle paul who i am
the middle namesake of him
justin paul sometimes he calls himself
justin thoreau
it's a french name it's theru you want
me to say we had a bomb
yes i do we had a bomb
the book was also made into a movie back
in the 80s was there any pressure in
stepping into the shoes that harrison
ford once felt
i didn't want to obviously look or feel
like i was cripping from him or
taking anything but you know i did my
best the kids
could get hurt they're not gonna get
hurt they're with us oh that's what i'm
worried about
in the seven episode drama the couple
and their kids are on the run to escape
the feds and
drug cartels would you ever put your
kids in this kind of ordeal
i mean look it's very easy the minute
you give birth you are a mama bear and
you'll do anything to protect your cubs
yeah i would go off the grid to protect
my children yeah
for sure i'm off the grid now i'm in
france that's as far off the grid as we
can get so
my cubs are good before becoming a mom
melissa also starred on grey's anatomy
and with so many stars returning to the
show could she make a comeback
i would do it for yes yes yes yes yes
yes i would
but i'm not sure sadie was the most uh
likeable
you know she took out her own appendix
i'm not sure where she would fit in but
it would be nice
she brings the drama honey we love a
little bit i know
that's me that's me i would love to go
back i did not know that it might be the
last season